und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und marietta slomka guten abend
über eine milliarde euro zusätzlich für
die ukraine das klingt erstmal gut
klassische deutsche scheckbuch
diplomatie aber wenn die ukraine sich
mit dem geld das kaufen können was sie
wollen und brauchen wäre das ja auch
hilfreich auf den zweiten blick stellen
sich jedoch fragen wann genau steht das
geld tatsächlich zur verfügung und nicht
nur auf dem papier und kann die ukraine
sich damit dann auch jene deutschen
panzer kaufen die rüstungsunternehmen er
längst anbieten bisher gab es dafür
keine freigabe durch die bundesregierung
fragen die auch in berlin gestellt
werden nicola dickmann berichtet der
krieg in der ukraine treibt sie um und
auf die straße in stuttgart und in
vielen anderen deutschen städten
demonstrieren heute nachmittag tausende
für den frieden und einige auch gegen
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine
schweres gerät wie etwa panzer liefern
ja oder nein die frage entzweit auch die
ampeln in berlin der kompromissvorschlag
aus dem kanzleramt namens geld aus der
sogenannten ertüchtigung initiative
besänftigt nun die ersten scharfen
kritiker
die ukraine kann dann aussuchen was sie
glaubt an waffen material was sie
braucht wir stellen mittel zur verfügung
um das gegebenenfalls auf dem markt
einzukaufen wenn wir es nicht selber
liefern können nicht können oder nicht
wollen den konflikt innerhalb der ampel
ist der vorschlag nicht denn bestellt
die ukraine bei einem deutschen
rüstungsunternehmen eben etwa panzer
muss die bundesregierung das geschäft
genehmigen ein ausweichmanöver sagen
experten durch die idee der ukraine
jetzt mehr geld in die hand zu drücken
werde das problem entweder lediglich
vertagt oder aber deutschland aus der
verantwortung entlassen wenn ich mich in
die ukraine hineinversetzen und die
mittelzuweisung das erlaubt was ist habe
ich so verstanden dann würde ich mich
als andere verkäufer wenden die in
diesen fragen was freigiebiger sind und
wo die bürokratischen hürden nicht ganz
so hoch auch der zeitplan ist noch
unklar gestern schrieb der
bundesfinanzminister auf twitter von
einem ergänzungs haushalt heute heißt es
es kann jetzt schnell gehen in die
ukraine erwartet unterstützung von uns
natürlich auch von den europäischen
partnern und deswegen kann man nur sagen
dass die bundeshaushaltsordnung
ermöglicht dass das geld auch schnell in
die hand genommen wird und insofern ist
das gut die cdu überzeugt dass nicht der
schnellste weg wäre wenn deutschland
heute waffen lieferte anstatt der
ukraine geld zu geben damit sie kauft in
deutschland ein waffen exportgeschäft
beantragen muss das genehmigt werden
muss die wahrheit ist doch bundeskanzler
scholz will es nicht und es ist ein
weiterer versuch es zu verhindern aber
nicht nur die opposition bleibt
ablehnend auch teile der ampel parteien
anton hofreiter von den grünen war diese
woche gemeinsam mit strack zimmermann in
der ukraine
er nennt den neuen vorschlag lediglich
einen ersten schritt es ist natürlich
kein ersatz für die direkte lieferung
schwerer waffen und es ist auch kein
ersatz dafür putin vom geldzufluss
abzuschneiden das heißt eine energie
embargo insbesondere öl embargo muss
weiter auf der tagesordnung bleiben nur
vier monate nach amtsantritt steht
kanzler scholz bereits unter druck
parteifreunde stellen sich demonstrativ
hinter ihn
ich glaube dass zu den stärken von olaf
scholz auch gehört dass er besonnenheit
pflegt und weniger die
perfekte in den vordergrund stellt an
den anderen meer gelegen sein mag wer
ist da sehr zurückhaltend und besonnen
führungsschwäche im kanzleramt schwere
waffen für die ukraine beide debatten
gehen in die nächste runde ende vorerst
nicht in sicht
derweil läuft den ukrainischen
streitkräften die zeit davon sie richten
sich darauf ein dass die russische armee
im osten das sucht was militärs eine
offene feldschlacht nennen das erfordert
andere mittel als bei der verteidigung
etwa von kiew da kommt es dann sehr
darauf an wer welche panzer und
geschütze hat und wie viel davon auch
sagen experten dass die russen versuchen
die ukrainischen truppen im don was
einzukesseln wenn ihnen das gelingt käme
da auch kein ausländisches geräten dahin
für ist ein von rechenberg blickt in den
osten der ukraine
verdammt schreiben sie der krankenwagen
soll kommen über alles blut der mann am
boden
er lebt nicht mehr
andere hatten es mag zynisch klingen
mehr glück ihnen können die retter
helfen das leben retten aber mehr ist
nicht übrig
alle fenster die ganzen möbel alles
zerstört die tür auch
wieder ein angriff im osten auftrag f
mitten hinein in das was man in einer
belagerten stadt noch alltag nennen mag
die ukraine sagt dass es heute
mindestens einem toten gab gestern soll
das neuen gewesen sein weiter östlich in
musik tanz geben falls raketen
beschossen unter anderem hier in den
separatisten gebieten stellen sie sich
auf eine große offensive ein russland
heißt es warten nur noch auf besseres
wetter in mario pohl warten sie auf
flucht korridore heute wurden wieder
welche vereinbart doch noch harren die
menschen aus kommen nur kurz raus aus
ihren kellern luftholen unter
lebensgefahr
wir gehen nur vors haus keinen schritt
weiter oder schnell zum brunnen rüber
wasser holen
bisher seien knapp 20 tausend russische
soldaten gestorben auf ukrainischer
seite knapp 3000 behauptet präsident
selensky und drängt den westen weiter
nicht nur zu einem ölembargo gegen
russland
je mehr und je schneller wir die waffen
erhalten um die wir bitten desto stärker
werden wir und desto schneller erreichen
wir frieden
auch im westen gab es heute angriffe
marschflugkörper schlugen in der region
lemberger opfer gab es hier offenbar
keiner
in kiew ist die lage zwar sehr viel
besser als im osten des landes kein
vergleich zu städten die harke oder gar
der fälle in mario pahl aber auch die
hauptstadt ist weiterhin unter beschuss
bürgermeister klitschko war flüchtete
davor vorzeitig nach kiew zurück zu
kommen so haben sich die russischen
truppen aus der region teilweise
zurückgezogen aber es wird befürchtet
dass putin seien gesunken das
kriegsschiff rächen will was war so
direkt nicht sagen kann weil ja die
offizielle russische erklärung für den
untergang der maske war ein sturm war
den haben meteorologen zwar nicht
bemerkt aber solche details
interessieren die russische propaganda
ja eh nicht dominik löschmeister ist für
uns in kiew
der krieg kommt wieder näher an die
hauptstadt das ziel der raketen laut
russische militär eine panzerfabrik in
kiew die ukraine sprechen von einem
toten und mehreren verletzten die
anspannung steigt in der stadt
gleichzeitig aber kommt das leben zurück
notiert
stanislawski team haben ihr café wieder
eröffnet wichtig sei dass für die
menschen
das gefühl der gefahr bleibt wenn jedoch
viele menschen auf der straße sind
kommen sie herein und lächeln und freuen
sich dass wir arbeiten und ihnen die
momente des lebens wie früher bieten
[Musik]
so sind trotz der neuen luftschläge auf
kiew straßen in den parks wieder mehr
menschen zu sehen einen regelrechten run
gibt es seit gestern auf diese
briefmarke sie zeigt einen ukrainischen
soldaten der dem russischen kriegsschiff
moskwa ein eindeutiges zeichen gibt seit
dem untergang ein kultobjekt irina hat
heute morgen die letzten marken bekommen
und die schicke briefe mit dieser marke
an meine freunde in polen georgien und
deutschland die so stark die ukraine
unterstützen
sie sammeln spenden für die
das konzert ist am nachmittag dann ab 21
uhr gilt weiter sperrstunde in kiew es
hat etwas von tanz auf dem vulkan
[Musik]
irgendwann verstand ich dass ich nicht
länger in der west ukraine bleiben und
nicht packt kam zurück und begann sofort
mit der arbeit in der
freiwilligenzentrale und nach meiner
rückkehr sich dass die stadt wieder zum
leben erwacht
vor dem krieg galt kiew als das neue
berlin trotz neuer luftangriffe sie
trotzen hier der gefahr sie wollen sich
von putin nicht ihr leben diktieren
lassen
und jetzt andere nachrichten des tages
zunächst zur corona situation da sinkt
die zahl der registrierten infektionen
in deutschland weiter allerdings wurden
wegen des feiertags gestern weniger
daten übermittelt das rk ii meldet 37
1568 neuinfektionen innerhalb eines
tages das sind 113.000 107 weniger als
vor einer woche
29 todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben
tage incidents singt erstmals seit ende
januar unter 1000 auf 876 5
ohne militär parade aber mit einem
massen aufmarsch hat nordkorea dieses
jahr seinen nationalfeiertag begangen
anlass war der 100 zehnte geburtstag von
staatsgründer kim il-sung sein enkel der
derzeitige machthaber kim jong hun
würdigte seinen großvater auf dem
zentralen platz der hauptstadt pjöngjang
wo tausende menschen mit roten
plastikblumen versammelt waren
nach einem halben jahr im all sind drei
chinesische raumfahrer wieder zurück auf
der erde die zwei männer und eine frau
brauchten rund neun stunden für ihren
rückflug von der raumstation schenkung
sie landeten mit ihrer kapsel sicher in
der wüste gobi im nordwesten chinas es
war die zweite von insgesamt vier
bemannten missionen zum aufbau der
raumstation
joachim streich ehemaliger weltklasse
stürmer und ddr fußball rekord torjäger
ist gestorben im alter von 71 jahren
streich erzählte 55 tore in 102 spielen
für die ddr-auswahl insgesamt 229
treffer waren es in der oberliga für
magdeburg und hansa rostock
und jetzt die lottozahlen dieses samstag
sie lauten wie immer ohne gewähr
78 14 19 24 44 superzahl 4 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf de und im zdf text auf seite 55 6
das wetter an den osterfeiertagen wird
freundlich am ostersonntag ist der
himmel im westen bei 15 bis 20 grad oft
wolkenlos in der osthälfte gibt es neben
sonne auch wolkenfelder aber es bleibt
trocken wir werden 10 bis 15 grad
erreicht ganz ähnlich wird das wetter am
ostermontag erst ab dienstag gibt es
deutlich mehr wollten und dann kann es
in der südhälfte auch einzelne schauer
geben dabei wird es etwas kühler
in den usa zählt die fotokünstlerin
carey mails zu den großen
zeitgenössischen namen und sie ist eine
der wichtigen stimmen der lac knife smet
bewegung der württembergische
kunstverein in stuttgart widmet ihr
derzeit die erste umfassende werkschau
in deutschland mit dem schönen aber
nicht ganz leicht wirklich zu
übersetzenden titel wer wittens auf
dennis nordsee das zieht sich durch ihre
arbeit das nicht offensichtliche
sichtbar zu machen zu zeigen was nicht
gesehen werden soll
allersberg hat sich die ausstellung
angesehen und carrie mailings getroffen
my work is never too nein ihre arbeiten
lassen einen nicht kalt
sie sind voller emotionen
es ist die künstlerin selbst
1990 die uns hier direkt ins gesicht
blickt und auffordert fragen zu stellen
[Musik]
das ist macht wer hat sie
die wird sie ausgeübt wie wurde sie
missbraucht um das herauszufinden hat
sich carey mails über fast 50 jahre lang
hinweg immer wieder selbst inszeniert
die heute 68 jährige feiert den körper
dessen schönheit verletzlichkeit und
stärke wir werden soft drinks nutzen ist
eine retro perspektive die
us-amerikanerin setzt sich in vielen
ihrer werke auf sehr intime weise mit
den themen rassismus diskriminierung und
gewalt auseinander es gibt im prinzip
zwei bewegungen es gibt die bewegung
einerseits per email booms durch die
lange lange geschichte der gewalt gegen
schwarze menschen zu folgen aber
gleichzeitig auch gegen die ebenso lange
geschichte des widerstands gegen
diskriminierung und dieser widerstand
und das ist das besondere oder wichtige
an der aufstellung bezieht sich nicht
nur auf demonstrieren und politischen
kampf sondern dass das spirituelle das
magische des künstlerische das schöne
vor allem das schöne ist dabei ganz ganz
wichtig auch geschichten voller schmerz
trauer
wut inszeniert riems besonders
ästhetisch die wandinstallation
wiederholung des offensichtlichen widmet
sich opfern ratifizierte polizeigewalt
mit bewusst verschwommen aufgenommenen
porträts mit anfang zwanzig fing es an
zu fotografieren
seitdem immer wieder auch in deutschland
sie lädt den betrachter ein bestimmte
monumente wie hier das holocaust-mahnmal
in berlin zusammen mit ihr zu entdecken
welche rolle spielt architektur in
unserem leben wir gehen ständig über
plätze und durch gebäude und die
vermitteln uns ein bestimmtes gefühl
entweder laden sie uns ein oder sie
drängen uns hinaus da ist eine dynamik
in ihrer konstruktion
ich hoffe dass der betrachter eine reihe
von fragen stellt und eine beziehung zu
diesen institutionen aufbaut und was sie
für ihn bedeuten könnten
warum sie für ihre fotografien welche
gebäude ausgewählt hat sagt die
künstlerin nicht per email beams will
dass ihre werke fragen aufwerfen
das was von uns gleich gehts mit dem
aktuellen sportstudio weiter und danach
gegen 0.25 gibt es dann die nächste
heute express und uns morgen wieder auf
wiedersehen wiedersehen
[Musik]